hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for another special edition of
the Monday morning podcast if you're new
to my podcast you probably think what's
a special what's a special one usually
I'm here by myself laying in my [ __ ]
underwear running my Yap but every once
a while I have a special guest and this
this person will not let you down this
is one of my great friends in this
business is one of the funniest bastards
I ever met in my life he has a new
special coming out on Netflix called
mouth full of shame
oh that's already funny on March 14th
please welcome the legendary Jim Norton
thank you Bill that's a nice intro I
don't know how to handle nice things
being said about me I know it make you
uncomfortable that's why I was going as
big as I could go I was feeling you
squirming one of my great friends one of
the best comics I ever saw just listen
just watching you squirm over there I
can handle personal things that you hate
far away we are from one another it is
odd my managers kind of saying they're
uncomfortable this [ __ ] giant [ __ ]
balls in the middle it looks like a
retired figure skater sorry alright
anyways I can handle personal like cuz
we are great friends but any type of
compliments of work I can't it makes me
so like you like watching clips of
yourself I'm gonna torture you for this
Oh drives me nuts dude I watched it we
gotta watch a clip of yourself when they
bring you back and then the people in
the room like oh yeah it was good it's
so [ __ ] okay if you ever do a talk
show and then the like and they play
either something you've already done or
whatever you're promoting I literally
will you know if they cut to it and I
actually looked two monitors see if the
crowds watching it at home and then I
just literally I'll put my fingers in my
ears if I have to I'll start humming no
humiliating oh it's alright do it man I
can't watch can they feel like they're
fake laugh and like they don't really
like it they're just playing along to me
polite I feel like that like they're
just kind of being nice to Little Jimmy
nort and they're just being polite to me
the only way I can watch myself as if
I'm file myself at a club and I'm just
watching it but the second that I would
I knew it was gonna be uploaded or
broadcasted and I know that everybody's
gonna see it immediately I'm like oh my
god why didn't I do that with my hand
what are this [ __ ] so everything just
immediately it's horrific but having
said that I I actually made sure my last
special
i sat through it I sat through a couple
of times to make sure that at least I
had like the look of it the look of it
right now did you do that with your new
special mouthful of shame that comes out
on March 4 yeah I did it obsessive I
probably seen it about 60 times but just
in editing I don't mind watching it to
edit like I go point by point over both
shows I want I know exactly what I want
from the Late Show pull this from the
early show I'm really anal about it
that's good that's good to have yeah cuz
I don't trust that like anyone M flicks
is easier because there's no commercials
you have to worry about they don't give
a [ __ ] if it's 56 minutes for promos it
can be an hour two hour and three so I
was very comfortable doing that but like
you said as soon as somebody else is in
the room I want to hang myself but I can
do it alone all day cuz I know I'm doing
it as part it's still part of the work
but once it's done I'm like I can never
watch it again
oh I walk out of the room other people
watch it okay can I see that thing
absolutely and then they sit down and I
close the door and walk out could you
watch it with me
could you watch it with someone you're
really really close to if like it's not
like somebody you need to impress it I
what happens to be standing up I would
be standing up with my [ __ ] hands on
top of my head like that like is it suck
be doing that the whole time and she
literally gets mad going shut she knows
at this point Nia knows to be like you
know she'll just come up say hey I
watched your special it was good or I
watched this it was good and blah blah
and I go okay good and well you start
like if some parts coming up that you
don't like what you go I I hated the way
I did this thing like right before it
happens cuz you like you don't want them
to watch it and pretend to like it when
you know it's not it's [ __ ] psych I
have that thought once it comes out like
this I just I just go just a noise I
just yell over over and it just it will
bother her but I've also learned that
yeah did just that you're gonna think
it's way way worse than it [ __ ] is
but don't you find the comedians who are
so comfortable watching themselves saw
something wrong with that yeah man I
can't I keep your eye back could
literally watch a [ __ ] marathon of
their entire career and be yeah oh yeah
I love that sport coat I loved when I
wore that the way I rolled those sleeves
up I absolutely love this was a dog and
cat thing you don't live in loop I've
got a loop a tear watching Robert Klein
videos because I we are having him
coming in and he's one of my idols
and I'm watching like Robert Klein from
The Tonight Show in 81 82 83 watch him
on 74 on Soul Train or whatever he was
[ __ ] great man yeah Robert Kline's a
guy that most people don't mention like
no one talks about Robert Klein anymore
as much don't mention Pryor and Karl it
and then Robert Klein is the most
underrated guy I think Seinfeld always
gives him a bunch of props and was
talking like how he he was that I think
that was one of his guys he liked Cosby
and Robert Klein I believe right and I
forget how he put it but he was like
sort of their age like when he was doing
those things in the 70s and he was going
to colleges like he was like that age
part of that generation so he was kind
of theirs right thank keep like Carlin
was more of a 60s guy even though he
blew up in the 70s I think people from
that generation remember him but it's
weird how some people despite their
contributions will kind of slip through
the cracks like that right it's problem
I find with most people that wouldn't
that are like that they're not into
self-promotion so if you're not
spoon-feeding it like the amount of
[ __ ] journalists out there they if
you just tell them you know like I'm one
of the edgiest guys on the Senate but
not that's to me too straight but if
you're you're like the I would always
like I don't know I would I would equate
it to Detroit that calls itself hockey
town like they gave himself a [ __ ]
nickname yeah like why are you hockey
town wouldn't it at least be montreal
montreal canadiens they have the most
[ __ ] you know championships they got
the fans would literally drive people
out of town I mean why cuz you're that
well no one Jack's in the King of Pop
not said he wasn't good but he kind of
gave himself that like right that
nickname but like how a lot of hacks do
that and nobody thinks that somebody
would be a big enough [ __ ] to give
themselves a nickname so people just
kind of go with it like people must have
called him the King of Pop cuz nobody
could be that [ __ ] a narcissistic to
give himself the nickname the King of
Pop we did and the press loves them
because they write the story for them
why they'll love a Rex Ryan but hate
Bill Belichick like Belichick is smart
enough to be like you [ __ ] are gonna
take any little thing that I say and
turn it into bulletin board right here
oh that's why he stands they gonna you
know they're good and I think next
week's gonna be a tough game and just
taking only good time and then if they
want a guy like Rex Ryan go like oh I'm
gonna win the soup
oh yeah then they love him I didn't come
here to kiss the Rings I'm gonna go in
there we're gonna shove it right up
their ass and then just like before he's
done talking their article is written
yeah you want to go four and twelve yeah
I love Rex Ryan I love what a priority
is I love it that he loves his wife's
feet he's the best but he loves his wife
too yeah his wife keeps him on the rails
I swear to God if he didn't have that
guy would hate himself to death
I see it like all that [ __ ] talking he
does you see like that's why I love that
guy when I watch him like he's used his
flaws I'm like oh my god this guy he's a
[ __ ] show
this guy's a [ __ ] show and he loves his
wife to death because she saved him you
totally see the whole thing yeah he's a
disaster disaster yeah yeah but he is
but there's something endearing about
that night you know I just started
watching football again I can't care
about it
you were view the biggest when we were
coming up you were huge camel Cowboys
fan and then you were huge Yankee fan
yeah I just I stopped I started going on
the road more and more I just stopped
caring as much I'm like I'm putting in
so much effort to these guys and then I
meet them and they don't give a [ __ ]
that I'm alive I had a couple of bad
experiences with athletes I remember
done yeah
I was wrong about the Jeter thing I was
a baby I really act like a little
douchebag I was [ __ ] he was a dick to
not time I think but I Way overreacted
on the year I'm embarrassed by that well
if you if you go to the psychology of
the way you overreacted it wasn't really
just your love for the guys and the team
yes you are a jilted lovers Patrice used
to always say yeah absolute lover
that's exactly what it is I mean you
know the the husband that becomes their
stalker is the guy that was obsessed
with his wife like you know that's what
I was I was obsessed with them and they
didn't love me my biggest meltdowns was
gene Simmons because he hurt my feelings
he blew me off when I wanted a photo and
he was kind of a dick about it and I
just ruined me a [ __ ] I killed him on
the radio about it and I kind of felt
bad cuz he was nice to me the next time
I saw him I met him one time he was
teasing me about losing my hair and [ __ ]
I just so wanted to be like dude do you
think if anybody's buying that [ __ ]
Darth Vader you're wearing a walk in
your [ __ ] head that's terrible yes
Chewbacca is here dude it is like shoe
polish black I mean you can't you talk
to the guy and you kids can't not even
look at but what I love about him is he
would sit here and laugh
along with you and not give a [ __ ] and
then just scribble down Chewbacca with
hair and the next day there'd be a
picture of him dressed as Chewbacca his
[ __ ] written on it and he would make a
million dollars unapologetically go make
a million dollars off of that he really
doesn't care you know one thing I like
about Gena and this is one thing that
Dan Rather interviewed him and he talked
about is he's a patriotic guy like
nobody loves America more than gene
Simmons cuz his mother was in a
concentration camp
and she came here and when he was a kid
and he remembers I did I think he was
Iranian not the biggest kiss fan yeah I
know you're way off far off yeah he was
easy resilient I thought he was Irish
yeah he's ah he's uh he was born in his
name is really miss hime White's I think
he was born in Israel and he said his
mother's Zig how old when she came to
Ellis Island and he tells that story to
Dan Rather about how moving it was to
have them tell her to put her armed so
you watch that and it's like that's the
gene he should be showing people what
does she do that because she was she
didn't know any better she came to
America and she had to pledge allegiance
to America to get in that's what you did
so she's a child and the guy put his
putting her arm down as like no no you
don't have to do that so if that made
Gene a incredible Patriot those people
were so lucky back then that there was
no YouTube oh that would have ruined her
life he should run for office never even
open a bakery yeah the Sieg Heil little
girl is now coming of age to make some
pastries [ __ ] you you Hitler loaf and
[ __ ] yeah all of that yeah picture her
with the statue behind it yeah you're
right there's no livin it down now do
you have any clips about you I there's
so many things on me that could ruin my
life that III think that it's almost
there's so many that they can't at this
point things I've said or you know
things I've admitted is the things you
know I think like [ __ ] I wish I didn't
talk about that way back when so I
didn't realize that it doesn't want me
or do you not care yeah I mean I just I
mean it's gonna have it's inevitably
gonna happen to everybody they're gonna
go like oh you said this in 2006 okay oh
did I yeah all right well why are you
getting your time machine and have me
apologize the 2006 version of me yeah
you know what a lot of it is is I would
equate it to the the Eddie Murphy thing
where Eddie Murphy put out delirious and
he did all that that material about gay
people and everybody laughed and nobody
said [ __ ] I'm sure gay people didn't but
mainstream did not and then when
mainstream catches up and starts to
learn that oh that's really you know
hurtful and bla bla bla bla bla to gape
then all the sudden he's just like you
know they talk oh my god they look the
other way Bob you know when you when
they talk about that part of the special
they act it's like well where were you
during that right I know you saw and you
sat there and left it the same way I did
I didn't I didn't know that I didn't
know what the [ __ ] was to that level so
I think you can do that with anybody
well I think what let's Eddie off the
hook especially with that type of
material is the whole lot you know I was
giving her a ride excuse for that
special young lady boy if that didn't
make me love Eddie nothing will but like
you after that you like all right we get
it
we get I don't know good for him who
knows I don't get involved in people's
personal lives I don't give up I don't
either
in not in a judgmental way I love the
fact when when things about let's say
any celebrity come out they could or
could not be true it makes me like them
more like it makes me understand this
this is a public persona like I feel bad
for there's one major actor in
particular who must male massage
therapist said he was doing stuff and I
feel so bad for this guy
I'm like he said what a torture it is to
live your life being afraid you're gonna
get caught for being who you are yes
yeah oh god that's gotta be you know
affect how much money you make because
yeah that's all it's also they you know
something a lot of that personal life
[ __ ] that kind of drove me away from
ESPN because it used to just be the
games and they'd show highlights and
just seem like a bunch of people you
know broadcasting that just loves sports
but when they started to just keep like
delving into these people's lives and
trying to like do like the controversy
[ __ ] I just um I don't know I just kind
of got away from it after a while that's
why I love the sports packages I just
taped the games that I want to watch I
blow through the pregame and I never
watch any post game analysis or I think
I just watched the [ __ ] game and
that's it and that's it you know the
Knicks recently my Hannibal Buress
retreated this thing where they did the
first half with you went to the game and
there wasn't a bunch of people running
around shooting t-shirts at ya everybody
it was a stop at you play not a bunch of
music playing at all I would have loved
to have gone to that game
yeah it is distracting and they think we
need constant stimulation and constant
noise like nowhere at the game I I'm
okay just watching the game I'm okay if
it's the third inning and it's a you
know two and one and there's one I don't
need I got bad bad [ __ ] manic stop it
basketball is the worst basketball is
the worst just because they run out into
the court and it could be like a really
critical part of the game 103 103 time
out there's like time for like one more
shot these [ __ ] [ __ ] guy comes
out of gorilla suit t-shirts at you and
[ __ ] and it's just kind of it becomes
like a Chucky Cheese you're supposed to
be teaching your kid the game here like
this is really important and there's all
these people with that extra excited
look on their faces they're holding the
t-shirt uh-huh I always I sit through
all of that hoping that I'm gonna you
know nobody ever sits with me but I have
this this is my little [ __ ] dream is
that I'll sit and everyone else would
just stared [ __ ] daggers at them and
they won't do any more I don't give a
[ __ ] about a bunch of [ __ ] my jumping
off a trampolines dunking the ball it's
actually embarrassing to white people
like look how little we can jump it's
humanly they need this here I saw that
at a son's game I had a great time at
the game but that [ __ ] they're like
here they come look crazy trampoline
[ __ ] guys it's like [ __ ] nine
white guys coming out there we don't
need him nastic s-- again there's nobody
blocking him either and there's mats at
all it's like a nerf hoop like taken to
the next level I'm sure someone's gonna
tweet me actually that's really hard
combining those sports but well I hate
mascots I think they're unnecessary and
they're stupid and they they they child
up the game like that I interviewed the
Philly Phanatic
in 2001 I like the Philly Phanatic Oh
smells those uniforms stink I try
remember about being next to the Philly
fan night the stench I'm sure they all
smell like that
but there were some fur [ __ ] out it's
horrendous and to me they just they do
nothing to make me enjoy the game that's
what I kind of always liked about like I
hated the Mets his [ __ ] mr. met and
that big stupid I love my lack of
imagination of that one it's just a guy
with a baseball for a head yeah mister
and then they named him after the team
only his stupid
was the first idea what are you gonna
about mr. met good he's got a baseball
head he's a guide so we'll call him
mister we play during Valentine's Day
maybe we could have mrs. met I actually
love a mascot standing on a street
corner holding up a tax tax thing and
doing a stupid dance when I'm sitting at
a red light it makes me laugh my [ __ ]
ass off I don't know what it is I think
they should have them just mascots
should be like in traffic like every 200
yards is just somebody doing a stupid
dance just to entertain you that's when
I need entertainment not when I'm
[ __ ] at an entertainment thing I
don't need entertainment during the
entertainment in between the moments of
entertainment you don't need extra
entertainment yeah and it's not even
entertaining mascots are not
entertaining I never watched a mascot
like oh that was kind of funny or cute
it's insulting and it's really it's not
I would say the Phillie freak the San
Diego chicken there's a couple of
classic ones where they were actually
funny that's about it I always feel bad
for the like when they slide when they
run and they take the big slide yeah a
little guy couldn't do it no I like when
like the Philly freak will walk up and
[ __ ] with the umpires and mess with
people on the other team and stuff like
it's it's I don't know like that's one
of the classic ones but I forget the Red
Sox they tried to have on a long time
ago was called the Fenway freak and he
lasted like seven games
people were just holding him with [ __ ]
they hate him oh it's like the 70s this
is when you could actually go there and
be a [ __ ] alcoholic scaring children
and then they brought this guy out in a
[ __ ] you know Muppet outfit that's
got the Philly freak but now they have
the Green Monster one yeah it's called
Wally Wally right oh oh it's like a pun
it's a mascot with a pun name yeah pun
for what the park is known for yeah and
then then yeah then they swing Sweet
Caroline during the seventh-inning
stretch just when I thought your YMCA
horseshit at the Yankees game trust me
it's bad but at least the you know is
the grounds crew that kind of looked
like all right
like they took this boring thing and
made it entertaining a little bit like
that was kind of interesting to watch
people still spell out YMCA was just
that that's that was always tough to
watch yeah I don't need to watch the
grounds crew singing what was probably
the gay anthem 419 for the 70s I don't
need to see them [ __ ] singing that
every seventh inning yeah that might
have been the like like they were so
gayer than the [ __ ] that they were doing
I think would actually be offensive to
gay people I'm a construction worker and
I have a big mustache and I'm the
leather guy who be like there's like
literally now gay groups to be like you
know you're perpetuating stereotypes we
go to work ins grey suits just like you
do or whatever but that's [ __ ]
hilarious
do you remember Victor Willis the leads
say did you know they were I didn't know
they were gay I was a big my father took
me to see them when I was a kid it was
them in Sister Sledge was the opening
band and I didn't know legendary you
know disco showed absolutely that was
that my teeth it was either them or kiss
was the first one and I didn't know they
were gay but I found out like I didn't
know what the village was a Greenwich
Village thing I had no idea what any of
that meant I didn't either I thought it
was cool the way oh that's the
construction worker guy quasi
construction worker
yeah I didn't know they're musicians
yeah why is he just a bass player or the
Indian Phillippi Rose he still he's only
still my favorite I thought he was
awesome I love this headdress I really
did I actually like the one who looked
like something who hit on Al Pacino and
cruising Oh Glenn Glenn was the one I
liked I thought he was badass like yeah
that's why I never saw Rob Halford from
a million miles away because I'm part of
that last generation way if you wore a
bunch of leather and had a mustache you
would like some badass yeah I didn't
understand that there was a whole other
side to that I had no idea but now you
look back on old Halford video I'll go
back on YouTube and watch old Judas
Priest from like from that door was that
concert they didn't like 83 in Philly
there was that there was that jet live
eight or whatever it was you watch
priests from that you're like oh how did
we not know it's so obvious and I love
the fact that he came out nobody gives a
[ __ ] it's just Halford you know he's
like a big power top you know he just
he's a [ __ ] ramrod I just love the
guy nobody gives a [ __ ]
I think he grew into that role he looked
like a bottom early on I think as he got
older you know he get a little more
comfortable with himself there's a story
that he is a big dick he put some guy in
the hospital Florence he told me a story
if you put a guy on if you put any
person in the hospital with your dick
you're a legend and I heard that there
was some some hairdresser who for years
won an Alfred if I find it it's
consensual let's put that out there
yeah clip kitchen and they're over 80 I
mean I'm talking you know the asterisk
is that it's an adult in a consensual
relationship or consensual encounter and
you willingly allow him to put your dick
and your honor to the hospital
that guy's a legend oh just picture the
interview afterwards with the [ __ ]
another person at what moment did you
realize you were in over your head yeah
when I was put up when I told him he has
to pull it out and I realized there was
still four more inches to go yeah there
was some moment where he realized this
was a bad decision but I heard you this
bugging Halford to [ __ ] him and he was a
hairdresser or whatever he was it was
whoever the guy is that Halford Oh
[ __ ] in sent to the hospital and
Halford finally did it and he the guy oh
you hate [ __ ] him alright fine I'll
give you a rockstar dick yeah here he's
packing like an animal so there's
nothing but good good thing you think he
did it right before a show so he's
wearing all that [ __ ] awful studded
[ __ ] it's the sound of your screaming in
his [ __ ] milky thighs rubber leather
pants I'm sorry everybody
sorry to paint that visual he smells
good too I interviewed him before a show
on time me and this guy Troy from the
show went to the I guess was a gardener
wherever they were they mentally he
smells so [ __ ] good so I bought the
same Cologne a lot of times I'll smell
Cologne that British rock stars have on
and I'll buy it and it's very specific
it never because they submit gay British
rock stars are just British rock stars
know oz he's not gay Aziz Aziz the
best-smelling guy in music cause he
smells better than anybody Rob Halford
smells great I would never guess that
with Ozzy ass I'm not saying that you
know just you wouldn't think that he
smelled you and that you wouldn't
associate him with like a really rich
guy smell but Ozzy you can smell from
down the hall and he has it I think in
his hair or whatever it's this British
Cologne and he [ __ ] he smells [ __ ]
amazing
he smells amazing Halford also smelled
good but it never smells good on me i
buy it and i just smell like garbage how
do you know I can I smell it on myself
I'm like it stinks I thought you can't
really smell yourself oh you're the
Cologne you can't I put it on and it's
great for a minute and I probably know
like sure I'm like look you suck yeah
but that's self-hatred
no but I don't I never get compliments
on it no one's ever said hey you smell
great now like you know when Ozzy walks
you be like you [ __ ] smell that's the
first thing I noticed about first time I
met him was with jim Florentine in 97
and the first thing that struck me is
this guy smells amazing because I like
they're not getting enough ass
you know I mean they got a shell like
Jesus Christ that's what you got a
[ __ ] send your wife into the next
room yeah go get some when you hose that
[ __ ] off for you police I can still be
married at the end of this how funny is
that that he just you know he had the
whole thing with shower we got caught
having the affair and he's not I love
that the damage control
Ozzie does in an interview he's like
well I'm a [ __ ] I'm in a [ __ ] band
aren't I like that's his reasoning like
what do you expect other that was the
greatest yet something you say to your
friends though you don't say that in an
interview if I'm planning my [ __ ] it
said that I am too far if it doesn't get
him divorced I'm a piece of it
look I [ __ ] I did the amount of
[ __ ] people that aren't in his
position that can easily sit back you
know your [ __ ] life is is you're not
in a band you don't have all these women
[ __ ] throwing themselves out here
like what the [ __ ] is he supposed to do
I know I know I'm only but you had it
used you you're like a grounded guy like
I really mean that like I look at you
you're married you have a baby and like
you you're I [ __ ] booze Jim that's
what he's out in the green room until
everybody leaves and I booze dearly yeah
I admire I sit there and I just tell
stories with people they bring a bottle
in and I'm with like four or five other
but I did it the last night I was just
in uh
where the [ __ ] was I stand up live in
Phoenix and they brought it they had
this bottle for us and for three days we
just would you know taking a third a
third and a third and by last night you
know we're just sitting in there I go to
cigar bars
I just basically oh but dude I always
used to look like [ __ ] Ralph Malph
too so it was never really a problem you
know what I mean I wasn't like a [ __ ]
like Geraldo rest his soul I mean that
guy was like a [ __ ] great looking
those those guys you feel funny and he
had a he had like I always had like a
really you know angry [ __ ] energy so
like most women who had even remotely
had a decent father or maybe an uncle
that they spoke to had a nice
conversation once would be running for
the hills and I would get these absolute
[ __ ] lunatics that would come up to
me and you know so it kind of took care
of itself
to be honest with you it is scary when
you meet women and like the girls you
dated first or for a while when you
realize I represent something to her
like I'm an average-looking god and
there's some girls I've dated who were
better a lot better looking that I
deserved and I knew that they were
mental things I'm like I represent
something weird to her it's a father
yeah mouth full of shame I would say
that you know yeah monster rain I mean
the names of your spits very uh yeah
you've carved out quite a niche for you
yeah yeah you know I got I figure I
gotta be honest because whatever girl
tried to blackmail me I had to go try to
blackmail me one time she had no idea
who I was and we had hooked up a few
times it was a money thing not a big
expect we had text a lot of dirty
fantasies and then she wanted me to send
her money shot blackmail me and I'm like
well I'll send you money to help you
with this but I'm not doing it that and
she was well maybe all your friends
would want to see your fantasies played
out on Facebook and I'm like you really
don't know who you're talking to
I texted her I don't give a [ __ ]
everybody who I know knows what I'm
liking what I do at that moment I was
grateful to be me yeah you gotta be
could you you know what when you put it
all out there
you know they can't catch there's
nothing funny one of the funny I wish
that was a scene in a movie watching
somebody thinking that they can
blackmail somebody and they just
completely don't give a [ __ ] do that I'm
not gonna say the guy's name but that
happened to a hockey player he was like
in his 40s and he oh yes yeah he hooked
up with some like 19 years yeah it was
legal and everything and she's just like
I'm gonna tweet this out you know if you
don't blah blah blah he goes what then I
slept with a smoking hot chick half my
age he goes can't do it I don't give a
[ __ ] yeah and she did sometimes they
will they will at times do it she said
she was gonna he said he didn't care she
did and he didn't give a [ __ ] nobody
else did oh my god this guy did
something legal yeah she really not like
a leg just yeah he did what we'd all
love to do shame on him good for him
but if you're married if you got kid you
know there's so many guys that they like
I heard a lot of rappers get like girls
well you know special ladies a lot of
rappers you know or a little on the DL
as they say about certain things and
they get blackmailed a lot like I've
heard a lot a lot of times the girls
will go yeah I want $30,000 I'm gonna
start [ __ ] screaming in the lobby and
there's been times that stuff has worked
it's a shame Jesus you can't just go go
ahead go screaming the lobby stupid well
you know what if everyone was like me
you could and you like I wouldn't I
wouldn't give a [ __ ] like that's what
kills me like whenever a controversy
like that comes out like I like you were
talking about that guy with the massage
therapist and all that stuff I always
just think like I cannot
[ __ ] wait to go to his next movie
just to make this type of [ __ ] go away
cried to support it yeah cuz even the
worst case scenario is they did
something where they just [ __ ] up they
[ __ ] up well you've seen the guy goes
on the road he bangs you know [ __ ]
around and his wife maybe that's between
them
yeah does that mean I don't like that
song any better yeah those [ __ ]
people who do that [ __ ] well they just
go like oh [ __ ] that guy I'm done with
this movie really get done with those
movies I'm done with this movies when
his movies suck you know if he's if he's
not out there you know those same
[ __ ] people will still go to Mass
every Sunday the Catholic Church right
you know wasn't everybody it's like is
that really what you're thinking that's
just your fear of dying and not knowing
where you go when you die and you don't
want to piss off the invisible guy
alright my buddy my brother said it the
best he goes talk about the Catholic
Church he goes dude if that was any
other [ __ ] business they would be
shut down [ __ ] shut down I'm still
odd and I think of this all but the fact
that you don't believe in name-calling
I've thought of that a lot like how
negative it is and bad it is and it's
something not that I've had cause to cuz
I'm single at this point but we're in a
relationship with the woman I've never
done you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] imply like I
would never have thought and but I
hearing you say that and say yeah I
guess it really is a damaging thing you
can't do it
like because it builds up it builds up
resentment cuz people don't forget like
I got this weird thing if my wife dies
you know you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] I
don't care I know other guys that would
be like you know you like that would
actually it would hurt him in a way that
they would as a man they wouldn't want
to admit I don't give a [ __ ] but like I
I saw enough guys growing up doing that
you [ __ ] [ __ ] thing and everything
like that and I just I just I saw what
that did I was a little kid and just saw
it I just saw it it just it didn't look
you know this big deep voice yelling it
you know right it just was not it just I
I don't know so I just made a vow is
just one of those things I was like you
know what I'm not doing that but then
there was other stupid behavior that I
guess I didn't recognize them then I
repeated that but that was the one that
that I I didn't do so what'd he do she
called you an [ __ ] do you just
talking about what she's doing is if I
go all real mature
I wish presence of mind I sigh what what
do I do
you know I definitely say the F word a
lot but I don't you know well now that I
have a daughter so I really I just
should I don't do that I'm not gonna
[ __ ] sit there and screaming okay
yeah
when there's a baby in the world doesn't
really change that we can Sam my radio
partner just had a baby and it's a
everybody I know is having kids I guess
it changes the way you do [ __ ] right
yeah because there's that whole I think
for the first time in your life you're
actually aware of your behavior
affecting other people right with you
know with your girlfriend or your wife
it's an adult to adult things so you
really don't you're like oh this person
is an adult they can drive a car you
know I can say this stuff this isn't
gonna affect them you know but it's when
you have the kid and everything and it's
just like you know that this could
actually affect who they marry right oh
yeah this guy like that literally you
know if I do what I'm you know if I flip
out right now and I consistently do this
this could literally drive my daughter
to a trailer park someday right you know
and and be one thing if I was just
completely oblivious then I could just
sit at a bar go now she's a [ __ ]
loser yeah oh she grew up in a house now
she's into thing but I'm coming where of
the effect of it now and then I would
have to sit there and take on that kind
of guilt so plus I don't know I I don't
um I just growing up there was a lot of
just the the era when I grew up like
every authority Authority person was
just so not approachable and as I said
this and this is what it is and you shut
the [ __ ] up and it was that just you
know that's kind of what stoked the
whole fire in me I think so I try to uh
you know I think you go one of two ways
you either repeat it or you just
remember that so like um I actually got
a really good compliment from somebody
one time said you know he goes Mikey she
got to come by come by my house he goes
my kids love you and I was like really
he goes yeah he goes Abele you talk to
him like they're adults I was even aware
I was doing it like I would be talking
to like his uh ten year old right what
Grady you and I you getting homework now
that sucked I hated that like I wasn't
thinking that I was and they kind of
liked it that they were talking to adult
like oh this is this is somebody older
who they think knows everything he's
saying how
he hated it kind of gave make it
admitted okay to be like oh this sucks
I'm in hope that didn't make him not do
their [ __ ] homework but I would just
you know I would address it rather than
being like no you need to sit down you
need to learn that this is what life is
it's sitting there doing [ __ ] you don't
want to do like that's so much that you
learn that that you like you don't think
that you can actually go out and achieve
[ __ ] and like life becomes like [ __ ]
when is this over just staring at a
clock and people saying that I think
have the tires don't even mean it they
just think it's [ __ ] an adult is
supposed to like to say like you know
what I mean you know you buckle down you
do you well if I said that to anybody I
would internally be going shut up you
don't [ __ ] believe that I cannot wait
to tell my daughter I don't know I
cannot wait to tell it why is this blah
blah blah and I don't know why be like
well you know cuz I don't read my house
it makes me sleepy I'm just gonna [ __ ]
her honesty I'm just gonna own up to it
there's a lot of stuff your dad isn't
good at sweetheart you want some ice
cream
yeah did you want I I'm in the middle I
can you know I'm at a point where I'm 48
no wife no girlfriend like I you know I
don't know if I'm the best boyfriend
candidate but I'm tired of being single
like I'm kind of oh there you go that's
where I think of it you got sick of it
right yeah
I got uh no you know what I did was I
finally I just looked at like what I was
doing and then you know we have to like
I said joke about that on stage that's
like the 90th [ __ ] person that
doesn't go well and there's only so long
even do these chicks are [ __ ] psychos
yeah after a while it's like what am i
doing dude I chase him away in tech I've
had some of dated literally for I lose
people in text message oh I'm so I'm so
like I want to either talk dirty or I
just I just want to keep pushing the
envelope and the next thing you know
they stop talking to me so I know I'm
doing something wrong
it's not them then I'll talk it over I'm
just creeping them out on some level I
don't know why that just reminded me
this last night I was watching uh what
is that [ __ ] show with Andy Cohen
when he does the wrap ups of the the
Real Housewives oh not his talk shows
look what happens live yes that show oh
that one so my wife always watches that
show that's one of those crossover shows
I have to watch with her so we don't
battle over the team right right so I'm
watching it was Jennifer Lopez and
oh Jesus Christ just went blank on ray
liotta dude Ray Liotta was [ __ ]
hilarious he just answers a doesn't give
a [ __ ] no he doesn't he just answered
everything straight up straight up they
were like what
so for cocaine like in Goodfellas like
what are they using it was like cocaine
it would be like who's the most they
play this thing you can plead the fifth
and he oh yeah they never be never
pleaded the fifth what asked him they
asked him like oh you who's the worst
kisser of anybody he's been with this
person bennetto's person and you know
and he's doing all the things so who was
the worst kisser like this was gonna be
a thing goes uh I don't think I kissed
any of them and he goes well then who
would you guess and he goes Oh Sigourney
Weaver just said him they go who's the
worst actor most overrated actor or the
90s and he goes most overrated he goes
fan I'd probably say Clint Eastwood and
then somebody mumbled blah blah blah
blah blah was surely turns around he
goes I don't give a [ __ ] he is kind of
untouchable at this point he is Ray
Liotta he gets you know no but it was
real it was yeah oh yeah I'm going to be
dangerous he literally goes I don't give
a [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] I don't give
a [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] I'm Ray Liotta and by
the way I Who I am I don't give a [ __ ]
what a brilliant game that is plead the
fifth on one of these three questions
then what I do it was then it would then
passes it over to you and then you got a
you know and it's all this this you know
he did all these squirming questions
like it was absolute like Jennifer Lopez
okay when you you know I mean to even
propose to five times did you who did
you say no to and she's a nice person
doesn't want to say it and Ray Liotta
was just sitting there go and just plead
the fifth
I'll answer something like he just
completely didn't give a [ __ ] oh do is
you're two of them together yeah cuz
they're on that cop show together oh you
know it's funny I auditioned for that
I did Doug David off got the part and he
he I think he's better for that than I
am anyway not just acting ability but
you know he looked more of the part of a
kind of a slick like internal affairs
guy if that's what I didn't know Doug
was on it yeah yeah he's got a good
party brought Ray Liotta into the Comedy
Cellar one night Tom but you know I'm
not gonna get it I'd rather see somebody
I like get it
that's great it brings in a glimpse of
what your life would have been yeah cool
hanging ray Liotta that would have been
fun that would have been kind of nice
Jim you're next what should they say
about you yeah you know she going up
sorry it was my bad sto I was a good
like like she announces you before you
go on no I understand you're saying only
as bad as that joke was everybody
special is gonna be the opposite of that
mouth full of shame I I it's so stupid
to keep going back to this when people
listen to a podcast it's not like that
cuz there's no just know that right
there's no commercials coming in but I
just feel like I have to keep going back
to March 14th in case you forget because
then they gotta rewind and try to
remember where and way of course we
probably tweeted out I did love Netflix
- I've never done anything with them
before I know you've done a bunch of
stuff with them they're so easy they're
like alright just put it together i nee
Robbie had a couple of minor suggestions
they don't overly manage you it was a
[ __ ] great it was so nice to do it
and I'm actually happy with it like you
don't you shoot something yeah this one
I actually feel it's it's dirtier than I
kind of intended and wait the next time
you go to Australia now that it's on
Netflix like you'll sell tickets I hope
so
I'm going to you I told you you inspire
me completely to do I'm only doing this
stuff because you got in my head and I
hear Bill burn my [ __ ] head all the
time going what are you waiting for I
got to do it I really do it's like but
you were right yeah watch I'll stop
selling tickets and I'll be like you
watching Davidoff coming in with radio
watchin you selling out the [ __ ] what
is that thing in Sydney the Opera House
and I'll be like I used to do that I
know it's fine I did one show there it
was a TV tape no was it was TV taping
and something else and I enjoyed city
melbourne was good but Sydney was really
good and I might like Melbourne a little
bit better you did yeah I got in Perth
was fun cuz I landed there on was
Australia Day and everybody was just
[ __ ] getting hammered and [ __ ] so I
was like this this country's I didn't go
to Perth I didn't go was your first time
feels great in Perth is Bon Scott Oh
buried there they got the statues that
yeah we did it we went to the Bon Scott
wall in Melbourne it was like in one of
the things someone painted a tribute
wall to Bon Scott you know it's Bon
Scott because this says ac/dc but if it
didn't you'd be like you know
or as they say a Kadapa down there
why oh do they really yeah and then what
is what his burger can call down there I
don't remember
[ __ ] Royale with cheese yeah no it's
something a France no cuz somebody down
there actually had already had a Burger
King and he sued the corporation and
they what the [ __ ] is that you're
looking it up Jonathan did you sell
tickets when you first went through the
first time no you know I think I did the
first time I went out there was like an
O four and I did something for Comedy
Central and we flew in from from you
know New York so it was like six hours
to five and a half to LA and then
layover and then 14 hours yeah and
you'll and they let you sleep a little
bit and then it's like it's already the
next day and then we taped it and then
the next day he's supposed to go back
was so [ __ ] nuts so I was just like
well [ __ ] that I'm gonna stay here for a
few days Hungry Jack's that's right
Hungry Jack's okay that means nothing to
anybody listening to this but I thought
it was cool and I just hung out there
and I bought all these ac/dc albums on
CD that they're the original like like
it was TNT ace know the names it's like
TNT was the original album that then
became high voltage but their version
had like dirty deeds on it which later
became its own album and I'm an EP over
here so we went you know I bought like
all these you know cuz I got a big
family so I just bought them for my
brothers and sisters oh that's cool yeah
and drove around saw the apostles and
just driving on the other side of the
road was really [ __ ] up
and any time I went to take a turn like
the joke was I would just pretend that I
wanted to kill myself and then I
wouldn't actually make the right
decision because everything else it
doesn't even make sense you like what
the [ __ ] this makes no sense especially
when you're I mean you make a right turn
and you're sitting you're sitting on the
passenger's side and you got to go wide
you're like what the [ __ ] you just
picture like a semi but late at night
when I came out I didn't where the [ __ ]
I was at those with this other comic one
of those comics I do was from like
Scotland or some [ __ ] an expatriate I
just met him and I never saw him again
but uh we got on the road with no street
lights and drove probably maybe eight
nine hundred feet and the same time we
both went like oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] and got
over but there was nobody coming right
we definitely was starting to go up a
hill so yeah I'm sure people get
car service when you're out there Jimmy
that's what I'm trying i we oh bird when
I was there I mean Olbers there it was
great
but I'm also going to Norway and I think
I'm doing something Scandinavian I've
never been to any of these places I'm
doing all of them that whole run through
oslo helsinki stockholm dude yeah it's
the best but they say those are just
places that you know as an american to
actually go there i mean i think you got
to be like either you're either in the
illuminati or you're like a downhill ski
or some [ __ ] because other than that
you're not gonna go there it's far it's
just not on our radar to go there i have
beautiful countries and the people of
the people are great do you fly in and
out the state can i i have sleep apnea
and I [ __ ] I take Dramamine to fly
like I came this morning from Portland
so I'm like I'm very loopy and I'm tired
and you just do a show that night and
then fly out the next morning I kid
there was a panicking about that what I
do is I turn it into like a paid
vacation so what I do is I over there
and I either do the tour and then I meet
my wife afterwards or other times I've
done it like just because of our
schedules that work out like all right
let's do the vacation first and then not
only will I be rested I'll be you know
yes talking about to acclimated yeah
time and that type of thing so I've done
both but you know there's all you know I
build a limo and build laws [ __ ] around
sporting events and stuff like you know
what I wanted to go to this year I I
don't think it's gonna work out though
but I was gonna go to that there's this
motorcycle race on the Isle of Man which
is an island between Britain and Ireland
home saying that right of [ __ ] Wales
whatever the [ __ ] you want to call it
and it's just this [ __ ] motorcycle
race that's just like it I mean more
people have died than years they've had
it it's just really dude they going like
[ __ ] 200 miles an hour down these
country roads and [ __ ] and they go come
blazing through town I mean it's like if
if you love the beginning of the last
Mad Max this is like the closest you're
gonna see to the real version of it I
mean it dude these guys are [ __ ]
lunatics like they know that going so
fast and that digs little ass country
roads and there's like stone walls and
[ __ ] and trees like you're dead and
pedestrians are getting killed once in a
while - I'm surprised that so many
people stand so close that my only
nervousness about it is
how can I get high up enough to see a
little bit more of it right because I'm
worried that it's just gonna be like you
know I'm gonna stand it come fly halfway
around the world you see he like let's
stand there for like another [ __ ] 20
minutes because they go by that [ __ ]
friend and that's it yeah I went to the
Daytona 500 we won the in the infield on
like this little building so I could
actually stand and kind of watch him go
all the way around but like if you just
stand the first time I went to the Indy
500 I was just you're just in a corner
and it just becomes this drinking game
and everybody's bet on like four
different cars and you just pray to god
there's gonna be an accident or some
[ __ ] in front of you right just
something interesting yeah and it's
actually really amazing the first time
you see and you actually hear this tires
skid like a real accident you're like oh
yeah I guess it is a car for some reason
I never thought it would sound like that
but the thing is that going so fast is
they'll hit the wall in front of you and
then the debris just they fly down all
you seen the accidents yeah I saw a guy
hit a wall in for me one time but it's
like it's he hits it in front of you and
by the time your brain reacts to what
that is it's he's already a quarter-mile
away it's like they hit it let me stop
do you watch like boxing and MMA cuz you
use such a sports car do you watch
combat sports or no yeah I keep going in
and out of MMA it's like depends on my
road schedule where it's like you know I
work a lot on Saturday night right and
if a couple months goes by and I keep
missing the fights I hate it but it's a
big thing that me and my wife do like
she [ __ ] loves it
does she like UFC dude she oh she's
almost embarrassing like she gets up and
yells at the TV oh great she totally
gets into it when Anderson Silva like
had the compound fracture of his leg I
was like oh my god looking away and she
has this weird thing where maybe she
should have gotten a medical field
because she was wasn't like she was
happy it happened she was just more
fascinated by what it looked like he's
just like good lord oh yeah I always co
that's like the when they break that
[ __ ] thing that's like you ever see
like a little kid put on like his dad's
rain boot snaps on the side and just
folds up like I can't I cannot look it I
was at that fight that was their second
fight that was nobody knew what happened
like until the replay you just saw him
fall and then the replay played the
whole place that was a horrible but he's
still kicking
he's still using that leg he's I heard
when you break the bone though doesn't
come back
stronger some weird reason they might
have strengthened it with metal I heard
it was a pretty clean break here we go
we're going into the abyssal you don't
does it make it stronger you heard they
did metal yeah we don't know but he's
able to fight with it let's just give
answers Jeff yeah why it happened
I remember overhearing somebody say that
and I never did any background check on
them and have you ever gone to one of
the fights yes yes I did what is that
you always had the picture of him going
by on the stretcher Jesus Christ Jim you
look like you're in a [ __ ] band dude
I got to tell you this guy took this
weight off what two three years ago and
you've kept it off what are you doing
and I just just eating in the gym just
that that really is it but when did you
finally because you were you were you
were on those up and I was awful just
that moment of clarity I was like oh
just so much [ __ ] self-disgust what
were you eating and where were you when
you when you finally were just like I
can't do this anymore
you know I really don't remember I what
I do remember is going to the gym and
going I am going to go I was [ __ ] I
was just sick of like when you feel it
in your back above your belt that little
bit of [ __ ] fat it's just soft like a
little lamb I started getting the the
effort noises putting on socks I was
just like oh god I'm becoming that guy
so I just like this last trip I just had
I got off the road two days ago now I've
just been it's so funny I literally just
two days of not eating Burger King or
Steak and Shake and I never I just kind
of fell into this I think was just
because of the lack of sleep I've been
getting and just going out on the road
and then having to do the shows and the
pressure put them together in the new
hour I just been under a lot of stress
that I've just been like last second
I'll [ __ ] I'm hungry let's go here I
don't give a [ __ ] just stuff this in me
and fill up the hole and it just was
yeah la is dangerous for me because I go
this is this what a [ __ ] fruit I'm
turning into Jonathan and I would love
it it is a great [ __ ] fruit weed I
like eating sushi here but then we go to
the yogurt stop on Santa Monica below
for years they think we're a couple it's
my favorite place in the world is the
[ __ ] yogurt stop on Santa Monica I
love where is that it's on Santa Monica
by rage
let's talk just talking to Jonathan [ __ ]
yeah you just speaking of in Jonathan
brainstein everybody know hello yeah
Jonathan who's very instrumental when we
first started doing the Patrice O'Neal
benefit that's right always help me get
in touch with all the guys and
everything like that and it's an amazing
thing that's still going on it's
incredible yeah just like how much no no
no it's more in Tarrant Barney Barney
Tarrant deals with all the
infrastructure and the herd of a DD that
is booking a bunch of comedians dude
it's literally it's like you got 12 cows
just [ __ ] own I guess what what runs
cows don't run you got ten bowls you got
ten [ __ ] things that run their own
own a different direction things that
run all going in different directions
you go but February 21st that no only
one it is right yes kinda we kind of
know it's gonna be in February now yeah
now she lets us know in enough advanced
that's why we do a Tuesday because
sometimes fans go why the [ __ ] is this
on a Tuesday night it's because cuz guys
are working for free and this is what
that's the day comedians are are in town
so next year I already know like one of
the guys out here every year we try to
like maybe fly somebody in and we got an
idea of possibly who we're gonna try to
use this next year but it's been a great
thing is it
I just hate like you know like when
someone passes away like with
unfortunate we're at that age you know
and we're you had that one-time benefit
you're like okay here's your sack of
cash good luck for the next 40 years and
it's you know he was taking care of
those people so it's it's definitely
been a great thing so but and the thing
about here's the B I think it has to
this year is that it's the fifth annual
one I've officially done this four more
times than Patrice would have done it
for me I think might have been this year
I thought was the perfect combination of
a great mix of people the ball breaking
was on a whole other [ __ ] level and
then when Leslie Jones told that Patrice
story oh my god it was just [ __ ] no
dude the [ __ ] that you said when ode to
Keith Keith Robinson Keith Roberts Keith
unfortunately suffered a mild stroke was
a moment coming up on two years ago no I
say less than the yeah you're on
and he's yeah of course now he's doing
like somebody's funniest [ __ ] or
whatever so Jim when he out rode him he
goes keep going for Keith Robertson he
should've had a stroke fifteen years ago
the place [ __ ] dies laughing and then
your other one was like well it's funny
is even after a stroke keith is easier
to understand than rich father yeah how
how you followed it with the rusty of
jokes but people like yeah people like
the attacks on each other that that's
always a crowd favorite
you had one where you said I think Colin
came after you and you said ah he's here
he's has to be back at Men's Wearhouse
soon he was wearing a suit that night
and it was boss is awful hat this year
huh and Pete Davidson kept telling him
the truth gonna look awful and like Pete
that's not how this game works yeah tell
him it looks good you wait till he goes
out on stage yeah you don't try to
discourage him you wait until he's on
and then you [ __ ] attack him in front
of the entire theater Seamus it was
another another one that's the first
time we had him and he came out he was
thrashing Fausta's had I think they
actually make in front of us is the old
guys I yeah I think that but then wash
leveled him walk his peepee talks about
his dad dying on an 11 and voice said
the one good thing is that
Pete's dad didn't have to see him in
that blouse and he said he would have
thrown himself in another fire sweater
he had artsy golden girls sweater yeah
where yeah that was really bad it was
really really shitty I wanted to make
fun of it but I knew I didn't like it
I'm like you're on a TV show if you're
[ __ ] good-looking young guy and if
you dress slightly effeminate it's like
you're not getting enough [ __ ] so I
knew that that's why I was gonna come
out I was like I can't come in you know
the in potential yeah I I knew that I
was just an old man getting jealous you
know now I had to Rosa just showed up in
that then I would have I mean the
sweater aunt by itself should have been
burned it was brutal it was it was bad
but you know you knew the reasons for
attacking it would have been more yeah
it's that's one of those [ __ ] guys
remember those those all those people
that Madonna used to [ __ ] in Soho in New
York City those being Benitez those
artists yeah he looked like he [ __ ]
when he dies his artwork it was going to
be worth something
yeah like a young I can't move I never
Basquiat yeah
of age that's what I'm thinking of yeah
I don't like any of those guys because
it always makes me feel foolish because
everybody looks at this [ __ ] like it's
[ __ ] amazing and like one of the I
don't know like the two lays one I
always know that I'm a dope was when I
try to read out loud that and when I go
to a museum because I mean you want to
just talk about flatlining emotionally
and it just it means not dude I went
when I went to Paris I went into the
Louvre I could not get out of there fast
enough I was like literally almost
shouting at people like where is it
where is the [ __ ] where's the Mona
Lisa so I can look at it and get the
[ __ ] out of here and you get out of
there there's all these people just you
know just creating like a ledge with
their other hand and then [ __ ]
holding their chin with the other one
and I was just I just sort of I peered
over like it was the presidential
motorcade driving by a quick look that
was it did it move you didn't give a
[ __ ] the only thing it was cools it's
been recreated so many times to be like
that's the actual one that's it yeah and
dude I saw the Sistine Chapel I couldn't
be not [ __ ] small it was I think the
guy was dogging it I mean it's saying it
took him that [ __ ] long ha ha ha ha
Walken I literally was like this is it
in some way shape or inspiring that they
recently dug up Christ's tomb in the
church and they had to do some antic
they know where he's buried huh they
know where the supposed to move Christ
they do know yes [ __ ] Al Capone's
vault it probably is the Shroud of Turin
it probably is [ __ ] but I mean it is
in in Catholicism they do kind of Revere
its somewhere and you know Jerusalem I
guess but these guys had to go down and
they were doing some kind of maintenance
work on it to which they had to be done
on the lid over the tomb but like that
would probably get me like look this is
a pretty important place but the art
museums do nothing for me I did see the
Washington Crossing the Delaware
painting it's [ __ ] massive it's
probably the size of this room in the
Metropolitan Izumo that was kinda or is
it the well I would rather look at that
[ __ ] than something like abstract
yeah me too that looked like you've
rolled a baby and paint and just [ __ ]
through it yeah yeah and this I like to
prevent I went to the van Gogh one when
where where the [ __ ] whatever country
that's in I want
to that and I actually liked that one
it's not cuz he's a fellow [ __ ]
redhead it was just I like that it likes
with Netherlands yeah how about I like a
Norman Rockwell are you sure it's not a
Denmark I thought maybe it could be the
whole way you dressed me but I know I
know I know that you're right he has the
initials on his shirt he gives like the
air of authority but half the times he
knows we're talking about half the time
she does act on this is that way you
have your initials right there yeah
that's very unique
yeah the tailor is that near your your
pancreas is that way you put it there I
thought you did it on the cuff link on
the cuff you there's two styles you can
do it the cuff you can do it here what
is that and what is that style I don't
know I've always had it here though so I
don't know yeah the tailor that I got
this made yet he did it gentleman seen
it yeah John's a true gentleman yeah the
trying to tell how difficult you are as
a client cuz I know when you're not
around his shirt is untucked yeah he's
got a rock'n'roll compound case there's
chicks to talk to to the Greek alright
we're coming up on an hour here Jim I'm
so yeah I'm such a [ __ ] huge fan you
and I always tell you this dude I owe so
much of the tickets that I sell to on
the road that you were generous when you
got a lot of guys would have got that
Opie and Anthony gig and they would have
kept the [ __ ] door closed and you let
us all run in so I want to thank you
please dude you know see I'm blowing all
my money on Foot Locker t-shirts here no
but you do it you doing well deservedly
like your great comic and I mean it's
like yeah I just taught my compliment
with the compliment you son no but it's
it's it is nice to see like mouth full
of shame I've gone Netflix March 14th
I love you to death Jimmy all the
success in the world to you I will
definitely be tweeting this out if you
want to talk to Jimmy Norton you can get
him on Twitter at at Jim Norton
Instagram at Jim Norton Facebook just
type in Jim Norton and Jim Norton calm
and you can hear me in Sam in the
morning I have to plug my fam Roberts we
are now doing the show together Monday
through Friday 8 to 11 on channel 103 I
have satellite radio now and I'd look at
the list of you guys all the time it's
great it's really finally get caught up
oh yeah I can't believe how long I did
satellite radio before I got it it's
[ __ ] tremendous you just got it I
just got it I never had it in my car and
I finally just said I finally never
bought myself a nice car
those frugal [ __ ] douchebags so I
finally just said I'm buying a nice car
did you I was just like whatever they
said you want this I was like yes if you
want that yes treating yourself climate
control yes I just said yes to
everything that's why I get shitty gas
mileage is so [ __ ] heavy with all the
options that I have me man sorry I was
late - oh you weren't late Jimmy pretty
sure you a building anticipation I'll
see you guys